and I say this all the time it's
important especially in the the kind of
nascent stages of anything creative
that's ongoing like this is remaining
open and flexible and and being in that
space of letting it tell you what it
wants to be like not being rigid and
saying this is what we're doing like
okay here's what we're doing now but
let's learn like oh maybe it would be
cool if we move over here or we do this
and this is something that's hard we get
like calcified or wet to like this it
has to be done like this and I'm the
only one who knows how to do it and if I
have to stay up all night yeah whatever
I'm managing yeah but like the magic is
in the letting go and in the empowering
of other people and like prioritizing
your self-care over like those little
details that actually don't matter yeah
you know that's a that's a it's tough